welcome I'm hoping to hold one of these
happy talks I don't expect anyone to
learn anything so you can just relax sit
back and enjoy I have too much content
I've been warned about talking too fast
but I hope that I will that the number
of slides is just because I have a style
of skipping slides instead of having
animations in my slide because I can't
figure out how LibreOffice those
animations so yeah welcome to this talk
this talk is about customizing cute but
it's also about how to adopt two custom
hardware I'll be talking about Cisco
which is my employer where I work a
little bit about me and what we do like
what devices that we make customizations
we make I have three case studies I'd
like to share with you the real products
that shipped and are successful and what
is under the hood what we did really fun
stuff I think and also some of the
learnings that we had and as tradition
has it I never managed to get to the
learnings so you just have to soak up
the yes I work for Cisco so yes my name
is Andreas or al Hansen I have a master
and the civil engineering it's just six
months difference I've both at the
University in Oslo
I studied the software and I've worked
as a developer self-employed and
employed I've been a manager director
tin-lead and now I'm a principal
engineer working for Cisco
so prior to work I used the open source
development so there's a IMAP server
called IMAP which was a fun project
that I did in a period where I was in
quarantine switching between two jobs
and I was not allowed to work on
anything else I also was a cute
developer so I worked as a queue topper
working for the QT patroltec back then
for seven years I was in oka best
experience I have
mocha is to say that I was there when
local happened Nokia was terrible I
think everyone who knows what happened
who's there can agree today I work in
Cisco I have a great time in Cisco I
think it rocks to be working on on
network devices on security I love the
fact that it's green as in video calling
people means you don't have to fly and
we're also really successful both in
software development in general but also
with our devices and I'm going to share
some of that fun with you
so what Lisa Cade Cisco builds is
integrated video audio microphone
products so we do all the stack from the
fabric of the speakers to the angle of
the rounding of the industrial design to
the PCBs the layouts to the selection of
chips we go visiting vendors I was in a
meeting late night two days ago with
NVIDIA talking about how to get the
whiteboard product which you can see in
the open area there to perform well and
we have one software that we deploy
across all of our products we have one
user experience that we deploy we build
continuously and with Florrie software
straight on to customers devices in
production every day and nearly
everything is C++ and there's somewhat
and there's some Python and there's some
Bosh and there's some Java so when we're
selecting hardware which we do we
literally pick every single chip that
goes on to the hardware we need to find
tips that are high performance as in
that they've got video codecs that are
relevant that are 4k capable for
encoding and decoding that they we have
powerful display and graphics
capabilities we run 4k displays these
days at sixty or thirty Hertz the CPU
and that we have power for for
flexibility for the future and also that
they're suitable memory bandwidth on
these devices we also want these things
to not consume any power not have any
heat footprint to cost as little as
possible and to be supported forever and
then for this talk the most
and part is that we need software that
can be customized because we love
customizing Hardware we change hardware
to make it do what we want it to do and
so I think that when you're trying to
reduce memory footprint when you have
battery concerns when there's like
immediate resource saturation as in if
you do something wrong the entire system
locks up at least for awhile and there's
heat dissipation issues so you can't run
the CPU for so long that's that's really
rough weather for any type of software
and I think we've been very successful
in using cute not because it solves any
of those problems but because it runs on
a system where you can have software
running that does solve those problems
so I'll get to the point of that later
on this is the first of my case studies
I don't know if anyone here is used any
tongue bag or system Cisco video
equipment but this here is a very
popular one called the C square 620 and
I was lucky enough to start in Cisco in
on the very first day that time Barry
became Cisco I got involved with this
project and I met a team of engineers
and managers and everything who were
super inspired and wanting to dig into a
very ambitious product the Cisco sx20 is
based on an Texas Instruments natural
tipped TI 81 68 it has dual 1080p 60
HDMI output so you can run two full
screens on it it's running an ancient
GPU power VR SGX 530 which we
overclocked of course to 2.7 gigaflops
and the first hurdle that we ran into
the with this product was that the
vendor couldn't finish their software
provide bundle in time so we were
wanting to use the hardware at a point
where their software wasn't ready and
being call it arrogant as we were at the
time we were thinking we can do it
better than them so we decided to run
our own software which means board bring
up which means device management booting
the kernel all the software are
this is the user experience that was
expected at the time so this is what
people were had been running on older
products and being as a person who works
with graphics I'm sorry works with
graphics and user experience coming into
Cisco and seeing this even though it was
2010 which to some people is a long time
ago this was terrible we have a classic
chroma key like button on screen type of
OSD menu we had it was remote control
driven 16-bit color depth no animations
it was a widget paste which for anyone
working on cute knows that it for
embedded devices we don't do that
anymore there was absolutely no tests
and at the time it was full of legacy at
the time I thought it was full of legacy
these days I'm older and wiser I know
that it wasn't that bad I've seen a lot
worse but at the time I was like ah this
is so there was no UX no new UX and
by UX I mean there was no graphics
visuals design specs for anything new
because the hardware couldn't handle it
no embedded hardware at that time could
do what what our designers wanted
because the only high-end the hardware
could do it or could it so the beginning
of this saga actually was engineers who
were passionate about graphics and
pushed capabilities upward and
challenged UX into actually building a
world-class experience which I thought
was very inspiring but this is NDC tech
towns who worked on the rubble so don't
worry if you don't know all the keywords
here but there was a the we have we had
to build a custom inter-process
communication custom IPC between the a 8
which is a ARM processor and the m3s
which is a different kind of worse kind
of an ARM processor there was something
called a VPSs
is a hardware dedicated hardware tip
which was responsible for placing stuff
on screen it was also being controlled
by custom software that we wrote which
is running on one of the m3s and it
operated on physical address spaces
which meant there's no Mme
so the a eight core Linux kernel was
running with virtual memory and the
entire rest of the system is running
with physical memory so how do you get
cute high-level framework to render
using a GPU onto these frame buffers at
the time we were using graphics view I
don't know if anyone is familiar with
cute it's not so important today we're
also shipping software on the same
device and we're using quick to hold
your breath
step one we had to make our own display
driver and the way we did that was that
we first we reduced the size of memory
that was available to the Linux kernel
thereby releasing physical memory that
could be dedicated to graphics and then
we wrote a kernel module that exposes
that memory through a frame buffer
device or we called it a frame buffer
device in practice it was just a device
that allowed you to to get the address
of the physical space and also map that
into virtual space so we have a dev sm f
p0 and FP one for each of the two
screens and step number two was to visit
Texas Instruments in India and then try
to convince them to allow EDL initialize
which is like the first line of code you
write whenever you want to do OpenGL or
OpenGL ES and I allow that to pass even
though there literally was no frame
buffer and they agreed on that and not
only that but they agreed to merge that
changed that we did into their official
software which is published which meant
that anyone in the world who wanted to
use these Texas GPUs for entirely
off-screen usage they got that feature
which I thought was pretty cool it's not
open source but it's contributing to
software which is made public which I
thought was cool step number three was
that for each of these frame buffers
that we had which is 3
frame buffers dedicated indiscreet
memory for each of the screens we had to
create something called a pixmap surface
which is a OpenGL surface and of course
Texas Instruments had support for
something they called a native pixmap
surface undocumented and they gave us a
specification which is in the right
corner for for what struct you're
supposed to pass through this API in
order to give it access to precisely the
type of memory that we had allocated so
it's not secret
it's just undocumented that undocumented
theme goes throughout this talk okay
here it says in the Khronos official
documentation for egl create text map
surface at the bottom it says that this
argument here native picks map is
implementation specific which means it's
not part of the spec in it's pretty
funny it's a official function which
takes an argument which is undocumented
and then we had to make our own display
driver so what you can take away from
this is just a few key words but and the
fact that it's possible so what we did
is we built a cue platform integration
plug-in we override it create to make
our own platform integration we made as
many cue platform screen instances as we
had frame buffers as we had this place I
mean - we reused some parts of the
internals of this platform integration
framework like the generic UNIX font
database of native interface we override
'add platform window create backing
store we reuse the event dispatcher we
pretty much just looked at what the
other platform integrations did and then
we molded it to do what we wanted to do
the essential part is that we made our
own GL context which meant that we can
take over the parts were cute wants to
start rendering when it's done rendering
and when it's about to swap buffers
which is all graphics lingo for our
low-level stuff don't worry so we built
the plugin the plug-in needs to have a
certain name
we just littered the code with printf
modern debugging techniques and and then
just watched our logs and traced and see
we know what happens and it took it took
months to get this run but it's not no
more than I would say four or five
months before we had this thing running
and we of course all of Q platform
integration is undocumented so we have
the source code and having the source
code of a framework like this I think is
extremely valuable and it's actually one
of the points of this talk that as long
as you know C++ and you have like the
guts you can always walk the code and
you can figure out how this works and it
makes helps to have somebody next to you
while you're doing so okay so step five
integrating with this VPSs compositor so
now that we have a cute application with
the platform integration which is able
to render into surfaces we needed to get
that Hardware block which says what
should go on screen to know when it
should show each of these frame buffers
which are in memory and we didn't have
any way to communicate so what we did is
that we built a very basic IPC mechanism
based on pipes and then we stored data
inside of the header or each of these
frame buffers with tokens to indicate
which of the three frames in a triple
buffer were current so we got triple
buffering for those who know what that
is it means no tearing it's very
important when you do low-level
development and it's something you can
take for granted when you work on on
high-level frameworks but we didn't have
that so we had to make our own so this
is pretty much what we got in the end
which I'm really proud of which is a 60
frames per second tear free analog clock
and I think it all really boils down to
a lot of work for a little gain and
actually a lot of the PM's were hating
us for spending so much time on this but
the magic happened when this product hit
the market because what happened was
there were pictures of it there were
videos of it and people loved it and
sales loved it we had our executives
pull it up on screen in front
in advance and brag about it so what
they were bragging about wasn't the 4k
the video encoding it wasn't about all
of these features which were part of the
backlog what they were bragging about
was like a blue scale and an analog
clock which i think is pretty cool and
just for the record this is the qml code
which is vanilla qml because this is
everything that's above that platform
integration is then they lack used so
this is the actual qml code that takes
to do that clock there's a background
image there's an hour hand which is
semi-transparent there's a minute hand
which is semi-transparent we made a
clock model which is in C++ probably a
different talk but we bound with using
property bindings we bound the hours
property of the clock to one hand and
the minute to another hand and apply the
transformation and that's sort of the
clock it's pretty cool
and it's all done using OpenGL oh pretty
cool okay case number two where it's a
clock by the way do we have anything
wrong now we're doing fine so here's a
case number two now Cisco SX 80 is a way
more powerful platform this is the
angriest codec we ever made the
industrial designers I don't know what
they were thinking probably that
everyone who works with internal systems
and sis are guys I don't know it's her
it looks really angry and masculine I
think the product would end up looking
like this with two pan tilt zoom cameras
very high-end audio and video
capabilities dual HDMI again actually a
third option option for a third screen
and the issue with this one was that the
hardware that was selected was a tiled
DX 36 and I don't know if anyone has
heard of a tile tile era Facebook used
them for data centers it's a chip which
is at the time 36 cores which was
unheard of at that time but now today
you could do 36 course just buy it off
online for your desktop PC at home but
this was for an embedded chip it was
quite unheard of but the problem was it
it hadn't no other tips so there was
just 36 course no display GPU frame
before anything because nobody needed it
and because the
pm's who decided that we should go for
this hardware didn't care about graphics
didn't care about user experience and
wanted that chroma key 16-bit crap to
run on our devices and then again they
were saying there is no display there is
no frame buffer there's no GPU even now
last time you had a GPU this time you
don't have one but again from
engineering we had a I would say what we
had a very strong push among engineers
who were very passionate about graphics
to get this thing up to speed this is
supposed to be our flagship what do you
do cute for one did not support tiled DX
it still doesn't all of our patches I
just mentioned they are publicly
available but we haven't up streamed
them up until along like five years ago
there was a legal reason and after that
I think this platform is actually dead
so I wouldn't bother anyone with wanting
to keep this thing up-to-date it would
be us keeping it up to date essentially
so I'm okay it had its own GCC that's
awesome like a fork of GCC which was way
behind all the latest developments it
had its own instruction set so I mean
it's an assembly language that nobody
needed
there was no Docs online you couldn't
Google anything it was all part of this
big fat manual that we got which was
full of mistakes it had its own concept
of atomic operations and intrinsics
there were none of the GCC intrinsics
that worked so if you wanted to do an
atomic clock or a spin lock you had to
do it in assembly and yourself and of
course for tooth we had to do that
there's no display as I said no frame
buffer and there's 36 cores which is
cool I mean all of which we assumed
could be available for graphics so that
sort of sparked very enthusiasm in us
can we make use of 36 course we assumed
so the first thing when you're porting
cue to a new platform is that you need
to investigate if you have to make
something called a custom MK spec MK
specs are pretty much a combination of
aq make configuration and they play
form header file which define which C++
compilers you're supposed to use as when
you're using cue make it's going to call
your compiler and you need to tell it
how you also instructed how to do like
default Flags parts and libs and all
that so we had to make it use the tile
jpg plus plus instead of GCC and others
then yeah some very short tips I guess
that MK specs are hard to get right from
the beginning but there's usually inside
of the cute base MK specs folder there's
a comment folder there's a lot of pieces
that you can make use of and usually all
you have to do is like change a few
flags you usually get away with with
getting default settings but one of the
major things that we did is that we had
to convince cute that we had OpenGL
because cute we use cute quick for the
UI cute quick doesn't build unless cute
supports OpenGL so we had to trick cute
into thinking that it had OpenGL in
order to build the cute declarative
module and so what we did actually is we
made our own opengl library which
consists of all of the standard headers
which are part of Chronos so there are
free license and so on and the
implementation looks like this so we
took we made every single function in
the entire OpenGL ES 2.0 spec empty so
whatever you call nothing the only
purpose of doing this is so that the
test that cute has to check if you have
OpenGL support passes because it all it
does is compile if it compiles it works
right and then also we the cute
declarative module links against cute
OpenGL acute OpenGL only cares of it
link I mean there's no runtime tech to
see if it's real so we got away with
that then we tried to build them so
building cute with the custom tool chain
I think as a very very geeky interest I
have I think it's really cool because
what you do is you you your your
compiling code which already is
supported by 20 or so different
esoteric platforms and you'd be
surprised at how often passes there's so
much of that code that is has been
through so much rough weather as in
it's very very compatible we we actually
had in the beginning we had compiler
errors which were typically warnings in
third-party code but actually we had
patches on those we dropped them after a
while because they ended up being fixed
upstream many of the warnings were
because of the tiler a platform GCC
which was old and cute was new so
getting new code to work with old
compilers and those patches we never
upstream because who wants that
so also there's some low-level things
like inotify support on I notified to
watch the directory on the UNIX that was
different on talero for some reason and
the entire queue atomic was we had to do
ourselves and it sounds like a great
deal of work actually in my team I made
an experiment
I picked the developer that I thought
was least likely to make that queue
atomic tile GX had no experience and
only did high level programming and I
was amazed that just the blooming that
happened on that developer because it
was like two weeks later before the
whole test suite had passed so learning
point to self as a manager being that
never estimated never make too many
presumptions about the capabilities of
your developers with the right
motivation I mean
so anyway cute build surprisingly well
so porting queue to a new platform with
our experience it does not require a lot
of work and I think this is probably the
worst type of platform you could pour to
because nobody else is running it step 3
custom cute okay so we wanted to use
cute quick too which is qml only sorry
it's OpenGL only and that cute quick to
module require requires queue to support
OpenGL so in order to build the module
we had to pretty much stub the library
which I showed before but in order to
make it run that's an entirely different
matter because then suddenly the cute
declarative library starts wanting to
make Windows and make graphical elements
and it assumes that these APRs actually
work
and we can't have any of that so what we
did is that we found an internal class
inside of qml in declarative called qsd
context internalized and I think you
developers were pretty fine with us
using it but it was just no
documentation and no examples so you're
pretty much on your own and we didn't
really want to share that with cute
developers or anyone but I feel like
whatever do I want to dig into this so
qsg context Factory is a class that is
used to create qsd context you can make
your own there's a way to intercept
creating creating rectangles and images
and glyphs for text rendering there's a
way to create a render context to take
control over the actual rendering with
render loops and with renders and so on
and there's something called create
window manager at the bottom yeah so
cute the rent the the window manager is
a qHD render loop that's how it goes
this allows you to take over key key API
is like showing and hiding and resizing
and updating which are you know whenever
a windows shown eventually show is going
to get called and so on and then because
cute quick requires OpenGL there's
certain requirements on a class called
cue OpenGL context which are expected to
create it doesn't have to work but we
created it inside of the show and and
that sort of got us quite far along the
way but we had a feeling that we
wouldn't get very far with this attempt
but we decided why not have fun when we
were first digging our hands in deep so
bypass the entire rendering so when the
application that we'd made had started
up own application started up we created
a vanilla widget and vanilla widgets
regular widgets are components that cute
is used to rendering so whenever that
thing gets exposed it will it will
trigger a paint and so on so what we did
is that we
a custom subclass of qwidget which took
a pointer to the root node of our qml
sin graph and used that to access the
render node internally and then paint
event in the widget would then do a
recursive descent drawing of the entire
scene graph using our rendering code
instead of OpenGL and what we did is we
used Q painter which is it's the the
most stable software centric painting
interface in cute so we pretty much made
a software painter for qml but which
bypasses the entire rendering loop of of
cute declarative of qml cute quick do I
have until half or quarter past quarter
past half game cool but the cue painter
that's another class because cue painter
sort of that's a that's a class that
typically has platform specific
optimizations and it's really fast on
platforms like Windows where you have a
lot of you have very fast compiler with
Visual Studio but also Intel which a
Intel platform has very or some
vectorization and so on
but it still is a single-threaded
painter and we had 36 cores
so with that impressive platform we were
thinking what could you do to cutes
software render that would make use of
threads now what I'm gonna tell you now
has been superseded in cute I mean sorry
this slide and how we did software
rendering for cute has since been a part
of cute so when we did this there was no
software rendering but it became part of
software rendering some of us talked
some of the people in Cisco talked to
some people in cute maybe we inspire
each other I don't know but this is
something that these days you wouldn't
have to do however the threading part I
think is still interesting so let's
study this example of a graphical
interface with a background image
there's a dialog some text at the top at
the bottom and a button and a two-second
button this is a classic very simplistic
or
presentation of a UI and what you might
want to render using cue painter or a
software painter so what did we do we
came up with an algorithm that was
suitable for a threaded rendering one of
them one of the things that it did I
would rather say the first thing that
the algorithm did well that it was that
it would analyze the scene that was
rendered primitive by primitive and then
split the graphics into segments in the
same way as an algorithm that's in all
days was called s buffering but in a
sense there's like a vector and there's
a vector of scan lines and for each of
the scan lines there's a vector of
segments and each segment contains
information about how to render a
certain strip of graphics so this here
would be an example of a geometric
example of how you would represent that
graphics as a sequence of individual
blocks or segments of metadata that you
could then do further processing on so
one scan line like this represents that
block of graphics that you seen there
more or less and though it is a block
diagram but if you if you sort of
stretch that out if you if you do a walk
like this like this way then you can see
that this a block diagram can be
represented in this way where you have
no overlapping now you can walk the scan
line from left to right and draw things
in the right order and you'll get the
same result and that again can then be
represented as a vector of segments with
a scan line itself knows it's Y meaning
it's vertical offset and its width and
the stride of the frame buffer its
rendering - and then each of the
segments needs to contain like the
colors and all that so I'm losing some
of you but it'll all be over soon so the
cool thing about this algorithm is that
it allows you to do perfect overdraw
optimization meaning that whenever you
have something drawn on top of it of
something else which is typically a
performance killer for software
rendering this algorithm allows you to
walk through the scanline and remove
everything which is drawn on top of
afterwards and that's very cool because
when you have a lot of complex graphics
on top of each other
you have perfect obscurity culling which
I call it you can draw from left to
right with with never touching a single
pixel more than once and I was about to
say and Patricia who held the keynote
yesterday and worked for us at the time
one of the most talented developers that
I know she did work on the optimizer
here and discovered that it was a very
complicated optimizer which very often
was not worth the time it was one of the
most groundbreaking things that we did
at the time so a lot of the performance
that we actually have on the product
today is thanks to her not just because
of the optimizer but also because of the
talero specific optimizations that we've
done so I'm saying this is only how it
works in theory that's not true it
actually does work like this but it's
more complicated because we had alpha
blending and so on but this is in
principle out work so custom painting in
cute requires you to go back to platform
backing store which is one of the
platform integration features in the
platform backing store you can create a
custom paint engine and cue paint engine
has all the drawing operations in it
this is an example of the API again this
is not something you need to learn this
is just to show that there is a class
called paint engine in cute which has
draw polygons and draw filling of
rectangles and so on they're virtual
functions you can re-implemented and
then you can do what you want this is
how it looked in the end I think that's
pretty awesome because it's a 60 Hertz
analog clock and spanning two screens
and how many threads did we end up with
that's a pop quiz too
and but this is actually a key point
that that I have and that is that it's
not that we just got to it's the fact
that we managed to do dual screen 60fps
graphics with only two of those cores
and I think that that's the learning
point it's not that poor us it's that we
by doing this we freed up resources on
34 of the 36 cores that were on that
platform to do other things
finally case study now is the Cisco room
kit so the device that's out in the open
area there there's a WebEx board it's
one of the most cool devices I've ever
worked on
still working on we're doing generation
2 now it's a wall hung whiteboard you
can call people and share and whiteboard
and you can do white pouring two ways
there's an infinite whiteboard canvas so
you can draw like mega drawings you can
send the emails as PDFs there's a lot of
fun stuff but what's really cool is the
graphics and what's happening under the
hood and not for the whiteboard itself
but for what succeeded the analog clock
because after UX
had done the analog clock they they got
really we started hiring a lot of UX
people they got really inspired and
started making new designs which were
pushing our platform farther and farther
now that we had hardware rendering with
OpenGL on the sx20 and this extremely
customized but really powerful rendering
on the SX 80
so as the UX specifications got more and
more complex the screens ran in in 4k
designers started coming up with with
this which is sort of similar and the
key point here is not seen but its
animations running in full screen so not
just an analog clock which became
digital but-but-but-but animations that
are running on the full screen so what
our designers used to send us the 16-bit
nastiness sorry
here we go and I can't even do it with a
console so that's there you go okay we
go that's better I can't see my I can't
see my mouse oh there we go okay so so
now this is what our designers started
sending us hold on hello
tap the home button or open your team's
app to start and then in the background
you see these balls going and then
somebody goes and touches the screen and
then the system transitions in to a
wonderful home screen so this is like
what happens when you have I would say
engineers pushing on the capabilities of
the device challenging UX and UX coming
back with something that the platform
can't do but anyway UX was like we want
this animation developers go like cool
but how does that look on a multi-screen
system and nobody thought about that cuz
designers typically think in the box
sorry no offense to designers but that
that's a sometimes they need help too
to think outside the box the PM's were
like yeah I just said do the same image
on both screens because PM's don't care
they just want the product to ship and
developers developers driven again we
were like what so we have one screen
with this awesome effect and the other
screen should just be black that's not
good enough and UX was like what can we
extend that animation to the other
screens and our answer was of course you
can I mean cute only supports one screen
for the QML scene so if you have one qml
cute quick scene only one screen but who
cares how do you get cute quick to
render to multiple screens so what we
did then is that on application start
this time using a much more vanilla
setup we create two or three regular
vanilla widgets on startup
and then we create three for each of
those three we get to display subsystem
to create contexts for us we're building
on features that are it in acute from
before because cute and fundamentally
supports rendering to any amount of
screens so all we did is that we just
used the fact that we can create two
three widgets in order to build up our
cute as before and then we created a
cute quick window which is what you're
supposed to create that one window which
cute quick is supposed to run in but we
just didn't show it because we don't
need it for anything else than the fact
that it runs everything we already have
three widgets with some magic we should
make it work so then inside of our qml
scene graph we made three items we
declared them in qml place them next to
each other as in coordinate wise XY and
z XY and width and height and then we
used the geometry of each of these three
items to build a matrix a view transform
which we then applied to each of these
three views that we'd made and now we're
leading up to being able to render the
scene three times so well this is
different from the previous hacks in
that were not completely bypassing
rendering in one way but we're bypassing
rendering in a different way so what we
did here is that instead of we jumped
straight into the code in queues we're
rendering actually happens and then we
installed a static global callback and I
go to which jumps over all of the cute
rendering code and then ends up down
here so pretty much saying we'll handle
this and then what the callback does is
essentially to render three times by
borrowing the rendering context from
each of our three views making them
current and then rendering we didn't
need to do any recursive descent new or
our own rendering we used what cute had
before but but but the principle in the
top left corner is very important to me
this is open source this is the power of
open source if you want to make a change
and you have an idea that it might work
then just do it you can just jump in and
make the code change don't be afraid if
the patch is ugly and you can't upstream
it that's fine but if you if even if you
can't upstream it you can talk to
developers about it there's an open
governance modeling cute you can discuss
on open forums and eventually some of
somebody will probably tell say that's
not how to do it however here's one way
you could do it and maybe even somebody
gets inspired to do it in cute or you
could do it yourself so rendering
capabilities for multiple screens okay
but here are these balls now our
designers decided to make balls that are
not RGB there are some esoteric parts of
the color I mean they're not ready red
green and blue they're from very
esoteric parts of the of the color space
so gradients in colors that do not they
are not in red or green or blue are
really bad for RGB displays and this is
this is something that is very often
pops up on UX meets the real world
because our displays are 24-bit RGB or
maybe in why you read rhythm or see you
CMYK there's different color spaces
which don't map to RGB really well
unless you're on HDR which you are in
HDR displays you have a little bit more
color space but still gradients on these
balls typically create a lot of banding
and aliasing effects and when those are
supposed to blend on top of each other
it gets a much force so first what we
did
so this here is actual called what you'd
see a mat board if you press the home
button for a few seconds and see that's
hello experience is a shader effect now
shader effects are there they're easy to
understand for people who know OpenGL
and if you don't know OpenGL it looks
like black magic but the principle is
that you define for coordinates in the
each corner of the other ball and then
you define you using a vertex shader and
then using a fragment shader you define
what the color should be for every
single pixel inside of that rectangle
and the color as we made it is decided
based on the distance of each pixel from
the center of the ball which could
create a shaded bob and then on top of
this we apply some deterring effects to
get the banding to be right but so this
here is how we do the actual shader
effect of those poles in OpenGL but we
also have the SX ad so there are six 20
DP you now the room kit systems are
using a GPU and NVIDIA Tegra x1 quite
cool GPU but the spore SX 80 in the
middle which is still supported
unfortunately has our custom rendering
thing which doesn't have shaders and all
that so what we did there is we just
built a cannabis-based one instead and
canvas think UML is just like HTML
canvas it's a 2d painting interface we
just drew the same ball using software
and and it worked and the funny thing is
that that old two core SX 80 platform it
performs at like half of the performance
of the Nvidia one which i think is quite
impressive it's very cool
before I do that
I love the industrial design I have to
brag about that it's not something I
have anything to do with but I just love
how we have people working with I keep
repeating myself I'm sorry if I did that
but but like the corner radius and the
feel the texture of the cloth of the
speaker's the alignment there's a
microphone array on some of our products
which means that we can position people
based on when they talk we know where
they're talking from which allows the
cameras to track in on that person so
you can track the speaker but this is to
4k 60 displays and this was recorded
this morning so Martin who's a colleague
he waves his hand
hello and then look at the balls wander
from screen to screen I think that's
pretty cool now
so this is like engineers and UX
who had like a love child this is this
is fantastic
I think our PMS were like what a waste
of time but our executives and our
customers and sales have this thing on
stage all the time and they're showing
off this awesome graphics running cue
Thank You Mel multi-screen and all that
a lot of engineering effort involved to
get it working and it's not on the
backlog but eventually it becomes like a
key selling point and of course as part
of this also we got animations of all
other kinds but still
five minutes right I have 15 but that's
with questions right yeah that's fine I
only have five minutes more of content
so that's good why is it that we do
embedded device or embedded systems
development there's different ways of
looking at that one of them is that
embedded systems provide the absolute
maximum of value over effort and what
that means is that you get since the
devices are cheap but they're very
powerful you get a lot of value from
them and the effort one is like well I
mean sometimes you might actually spend
a lot of effort if you spend a lot of
effort I would say the value goes down
it's not a good deal so question is how
can you get effort to go down now of
what I've shown now is that there's a
lot of hacks you can do in order to get
Q to do stuff that it can't do and if
you're able to get cute running on a
device which typically for vanilla cases
is does not require a lot of effort then
the effort goes down you get more stuff
done which definitely increases this
formula but that's actually not my point
it's a deviation because my point is
that customers keep crying for new
features upgraded features and so on and
this formula here only continues to
generate value for the company if you're
able to make it happen from an
engineering point of view and embedded
devices are really tough they're very
constrained but there's a rule that I
usually apply I usually talk about a lot
which is called the inevitable
saturation and that is that any type of
technology can launch and by that I mean
I've been in this business offer for
quite some time and I've seen projects
launch and I've seen projects fail and
you always end up with having some sort
of a minimal viable specification that
allows you to launch the product but the
problem is what happens after that
because after the product is out in the
customers hands the only way to come
he knew making money or keeping that
product out in the market and valuable
is to make better use of it but what we
typically do is we clatter things up on
top of it and it gets slower and slower
and slower you see that whenever you
have like a set-top box if you have like
a get box or you have whatever they're
called ulti box box they get slower and
slower and slower and then they go out I
here's version two and then you buy that
and then it's fast and then a couple of
months later is slower and then it's
lower and then it's lower and it's
because of this rule it's because new
things start getting bundling in the key
is to find languages and technologies
that allow you to continue to make use
of the platform in a way that doesn't
make the device slower and slower and
slower now for us cute has been a big
success
the sx20 that I showed in the beginning
was launched in 2011 and we had it live
and shipping just until a couple of
months ago that's when we end up life
did and end of life that means we're
gonna be shipping software for five more
years it still has all of the features
same with SX 80 and the same with the
other platforms too we're scaling down
on a few things of course but the
platform itself is quite lean so when I
620 by taking software rendered classic
UI and moving it onto the GPU what we
got was a first-class Hardware driven
graphics like modern graphics experience
but we also made use of a GPU chip and
we offloaded the CPU which meant that
the CPU can be done further used for
other things the CPU was near idling at
the point until we saturated it but they
a 680 same thing we managed to squeeze
the GUI down to one or two cores one in
call to outside call and that meant that
all the other cores were available for
doing what we today do is like facial
recognition and so on pretty cool stuff
and today that device out there is a 60
Hertz 4k display we're running on one
out of eight cores and we're running at
15% CP
and we're still getting squeezed for
using less the white board the white
board is running a nvidia tegra TX one
so it's the same essential chip as in
the Nvidia is in as in this switch the
Nvidia switch except Nvidia has some
customizations of their own that I put
on that but it's essentially the same
thing today there's a TX 2
and there's a TX 3 which are just twice
or four times as powerful as that one
but it comes with a Jetson like an SDK
and the eval board that you can get
which are really nice so getting started
with development this is very easy so
and I mean cute supports that thing out
of the box as a single display as with
cute vanilla qml and also what we did is
that we hacked the hardware in order to
get two or three HDMI outputs on it
which it does not have we made all of
the we made our own like we made a PC
air was a cold bike I think we used one
of the embedded display ports and we
upgraded that to be an HDMI port and we
did a lot of crazy stuff so we do more
with that hardware than they can do and
that's why we had to act cute to get it
to make use of it can I have time for
just a very quick cute is extremely
customizable you can either do it
yourself you can get consultants to help
cute as consultants okay that has but
there's also a community that can help
there's a very friendly community you
can hack the code yourself there's also
an open governance model it's a whole
different talk but you can actually push
changes to cute yourself which i think
is pretty awesome I also think that
we've had a lot of success with using an
open-source framework as a commercial
vendor cisco has made a lot of money off
of cute but i mean every single device
that we shipped with cute has had has
sorry every single device that we have
made ships cute with it and i'm my
opinion personal opinion i think that
either you can
like if you're using the open-source
edition you should contribute code if
you're not using the open-source edition
or if you're not contributing code I
think you should pay for license but
that's just me
so cisco has allowed me my team and a
lot of the other engineers to run off
with cool ideas and sometimes it's hard
to manage and almost always good things
come out of it if you're passionate
about visual effects why not just try
give it a go and if you run the demo and
show it to somebody important then
they'll probably say okay that sounds
cool let's do it if you want to do get
something done and there's a really ugly
hack that can make it happen go for it
it only turns bad if you know if you
lose control but as long as you keep it
playful I think it's a good thing to do
and the final thing is that I think that
developers today of any level of
experience should not be afraid to dig
in deep and by digging deep I mean if
you are willing to walk the path of the
code you can figure out how it works how
it works and you can modify it alright
so thank you for that a little bit of a
time - done yeah I'll take questions
afterwards I felt so thanks
[Applause]